I'm glad to be here it's the first time
in Sweden I'm Rachel Andrew I do a bunch
of stuff on the web
I've been kind of doing web development
since about 1996 which makes me older
than CSS and I've been actually in web
development since before CSS is really a
thing and I do a bunch of things I've
got to cut the products perch and
noticed so I do actually use CSS I I
work with CSS as a front-end developer
I'm the Austrian chief of Smashing
Magazine and really most relevant to
this talk is that I'm a CSS working
group invited expert and I'm Kurt of a
couple of specs
multi-column layout and page floats you
can find me on Twitter at Rachel Andrew
and my website is Rachel Andrew Cote UK
and you'll find all sorts of things that
I've written about CSS around the web so
I'm doing a couple of talks here and
tomorrow I'm going to talk a bit more
about layout specifications I'm probably
most known for my work on layout things
that CSS grid layout but today I'm going
to give a bit of a quick overview of
some of the things that are coming into
CSS that I just find interesting and I
think you're going to be interesting for
people to know about and know that they
exist but I'm also going to talk a bit
about the process that gets us new CSS
into browsers because you may have
noticed that over the last few years new
things seem to be getting into browsers
an awful lot more quickly than they used
to
I want to talk a bit about that process
and how that's actually happening and
how we're kind of speeding things up you
will find all of my slides and the code
and the resources at this URL I'm
showing a bunch of little demos and
things you'll be able to find all of
those online and play around with them
and I'll show that again at the end and
I've put on Twitter as well
so before we start looking at some of
this new stuff let's think about how we
actually get new CSS the process that
gets as new CSS approaches now involves
in with the CSS working group so any new
CSS feature is ultimately going to be
discussed and
specified by the CSS working group and
there's a whole bunch of us who are on
that group most of the people on the CSS
working group are essentially
representatives from browser vendors so
you've got people from all of the main
browsers you've also got representatives
of other people who use CSS if you're a
web developer you might not be aware
that a big use of CSS is in the sort of
publishing world so you have people from
epub and also who use CSS for prints
there are a bunch of user agents that
output CSS for actually doing print and
PDFs and things so some of those people
are also on the working group and I deal
with them in my work with multi column
page floats because those specs are used
a lot by people who are doing print
things and then there's a few
independent people and I'm one of them
and typically we're invited experts
because everybody else on the working
group is kind of part of a member
organization you know for instance in
Microsoft or Google or or whatever and
they send their represent
representatives there's a few others of
us who just do stuff with CSS and have
some thoughts about it so we're brought
on as well as invited experts so that's
how we get involved now all of the work
of the working group is done in a public
way everything we do ends up somewhere
that you can go and have a look at the
majority of that now is on github it
used to all be in a mailing list called
dub dub dub style which if you signed up
to you to get this absolute tolerance
and information every day and it was
impossible to work through these days
everything is on github so any issue on
a CSS spec is raised on github you can
go and have a look at them we have face
to face meetings and we have weekly
teleconferences those things are logged
in IRC and if we discuss any of the
issues on github that gets logged
against the issue so people can follow
along with issues they care about and
not have to read absolutely everything
that the CSS working group outputs
because there's an awful lot of it so if
you want to follow any feature a good
way to do that is to have a look find it
on github and you can follow that just
like you could a feature request for any
open source project
and when we start to talk about shiny
new CSS a few things it's kind of worth
understanding because it just makes it
clearer when we're talking about these
things so one of those things are the
sort of levels of CSS you know you
sometimes hear people talk about CSS one
CSS two css3 sometimes people ask maybe
where CSS four is now css3 was
essentially what happened when we had we
have CSS one and two and they were just
like one specification you know one of
the books I wrote early on I basically
went through the entire CSS speken and
wrote about all of it I couldn't do that
Steaks is far too much CSS and so CSS 1
and CSS 2 were just a single monolithic
document documenting all of CSS and by
the time the work we wanted to do css3
they were like hang on there's an awful
lot of CSS here and put it all in one
document meant the document had to
couldn't really progress and be classed
as finished so since it's got broken
down into modules and so when people
talk about css3
what they're really talking about are
those first modules what was CSS to
broken down into a set of modules and
that kind of became what we described as
css3 so we have something like selectors
selects has been around for a very long
time we ended up with selectors level 3
and that had the things that were in CSS
too and some extra things that were
added at that point so that's level 3 of
the spec but we now also have CSS
selectors level 4 which has some new
things in it which have been added since
then and so that's a new a new version
of the specification almost like a
feature release as it were but there
isn't a CSS for because we also have
modules and we're going to see some of
them today that are at level 1 they
never existed in CSS 1 & 2 so something
like grid layout for example started
life as a level 1 spec now it's not CSS
1 obviously that's something from way in
the past so we've got all these
different things moving at different
different times through the
specification process this is an article
that I wrote just explaining why we
don't have
a CSS for while that isn't a thing that
exists and the other thing that's kind
of worth understanding the phases that
these specifications go through to
become what we call a do a through C
recommendation which is kind of what you
might want to think of as a web standard
it's sort of a finish spec we're saying
this is it this is what you should
implement if you want to implement this
bit of CSS this is the specification
that you're implementing against if you
want to use this bit of CSS you should
be able to trust what's in this spec as
to what browsers will render so that's
kind of recommendation and the documents
themselves move through a process a sort
of iterative process as they get to that
point and they start their lives as a
working draft so that's respect that's
been worked on things can be in working
draft status for a very very long time
but that's you know we're working on it
it's a working draft so this is multiple
column layout and it's a working draft
multicores actually interesting so it
did go to the next phase at one point
and then it kind of got abandoned it was
abandoned in about 2013 and I took the
spec on last year and so I took it back
to working draft because there was lots
of stuff that needed fixing so specs can
move in and out of different phases it's
not just a sort of linear process always
if you look at any spec though you can
see all the previous versions listed
they're all dated when we publish a new
working draft it gets a date which means
you can go back and you can figure out
where something got removed from a spec
or got added to a spec which can be
quite useful and if you're looking at
some something older and saw you know
why is that disappeared or what have you
so you can hop back through those now
you can also go to the editors draft now
the editors draft is the actual document
that a spec editor like myself is
working on at the time so if I push a
commit to github it will end up in the
editors draft so if I push a mistake to
get hub it ends up in the editors draft
so the editors drafts are pretty nice to
look at to see exactly what has gone
into the spec very recently but it could
change it could have mistakes in there
and it's not dated you know that could
try
day to day what we do is when we sort of
got a good collection of work we go back
to the working group a summation to
publish a new working draft and then
that gets publish to the date and we
don't change those so if you're say
writing about specification you can be
sure that the stuff in a dated working
draft isn't going to suddenly change we
might publish a new one but that one
will stay there but it's always if you
if you look looking at really new stuff
looking in the editors draft will get
you exactly what we've just discussed so
once a spec steamed kind of complete it
moves to be a candidate recommendation
and at that point we're saying we would
like implementation experience we want
the browser vendors or anyone else uses
CSS to actually start implementing now
in reality that often happens a lot
earlier I say it's an iterative process
we write specifications browsers sort of
build on them sometimes the
specification comes from the browser
vendor and then comes into the working
group so it's a bit of a circular
process but at at CR status we're hoping
that people are going to start
implementing and shipping their that
feature in the browser and to get out of
CR status so to end up to become a at or
through C recommendation we need to have
two independent implementations of every
feature in the spec and what this stops
is one browser coming up with a new
feature implementing it in their browser
and then saying here is a new door
through C recommendation and that
feature for whatever reason can't be
implemented in other browsers you know
perhaps just technically it doesn't work
because what we want is things to work
in all the browser's in the same way so
we have to have two different
implementations of every feature before
something can be declared a
recommendation and that's kind of a bit
of protection there to make sure things
work well for everyone so that's a bit
about how we work on these things and as
I talk about different specs and
mentioned the level though out or the
status they're in it just gives you a
bit of an understanding of what I'm
actually talking about I want to start
with layout because that is my favorite
thing and say I'm not going to go too
much into layout because I've got a
whole talk tomorrow to talk about layout
so grid
one is currently at candidate
recommendation status and it's a really
good example of a spec that has a CR at
level one and actually also has a level
two in progress at the same time so CSS
grid layout the level one spec was
shipped in all major browsers variant in
2017 in fact most of browsers within a
few weeks of each other so we've got
this level one speck at candidate
recommendation and pretty much
everything in there is implemented it's
a very solid implementation in all the
browsers that have implemented it it's
really very bug free considering how
sort of new it is as far as people be
able to use it because grid was seen
which was developed behind a browser
flag so it's kind of it was in
development in browsers for about five
years before it landed and we all got to
actually use it so you can pretty much
be happy to use grid in supporting
browsers it's not full of bugs but well
we've got level one at C our status
we've also got grid level two which is
currently a working draft and the
original level one draft had for a good
part of the history and if you went back
through the history of that draft you'd
find there's a feature called sub grid
in there and that feature got bumped out
of level one because no one had
implemented it and because of this issue
of needing to have two separate
implementations of every feature what
you don't want is a feature sat in the
spec that people are saying this isn't
ready yet we can't implement it because
it'll just hold up the whole spec and so
he bumps this sub grid feature into
level two so we could kind of figure out
how it was going to work and it met
it'll hold about the progress of the
initial spec so subgrades
the whole idea of sub grid is that if
you've worked with grid layout at all
you'll know that only the direct
children of the grid container can be on
the grid so you can declare a grid you
can sit your items on it as long as
they're direct children in this source
that same as with flexbox you've got to
have direct children for them to become
flex items our sub grid or letters kind
of cascade the grid down through that
through the element so you could have
something which is nested down inside
your HTML but still goes on an overall
grid which of course is going to be very
useful I will talk a bit more about grid
layout tomography in my talk then if you
knock through my talk or you want some
background reading I wrote up kind of
how the specs going to work we don't
currently have a browser implementation
of sub-grid Firefox I believe are
working on it at the moment so I kind of
explained how it should work
once we actually do get some browser
implementations I imagine we will start
seeing those implementations relatively
soon because there's a lot of interest
in having sub-grid so you can always
have a look at that article oh come
along tomorrow could you hold questions
to the end it would be easier thank you
so CSS box alignment something else
we're seeing happening more and more is
bits of CSS that originally get into one
spec and then get moved out and used in
other things and this is great for the
web because it means that as we're
developing things you know if we have
alignment in one spec things are going
to work in the same kind of way in
another spec which is useful we'd have
to learn a whole new alignment method
for grid once we used to using it in
flexbox for example and so the alignment
properties that are in box alignment
most of those start their life in
flexbox and I think it was the alignment
properties in flexbox that got most of
us most excited about flexbox to start
with because we could suddenly do some
of those things that have been utterly
baffling you know why can't we do things
like properly center and item and these
things came in with flex box so you say
display flex a line item Center and
justify content center and your box sits
in the middle of the container so
knowing that it seemed out of reach we
could do things like full height columns
in fact the initial value for line items
is stretch so you get full height
columns by default if you use flexbox
now those things are obviously
incredibly useful and so they were
pulled out of the Flex box back
there's currently a there's a note in
the level one flexbox back saying look
at box alignment for the future because
all the new things will end up in there
and so they're in the box alignment spec
now box alignment deals with all things
to do with alignment and also space
distribution because an awful lot of
alignment on the web is actually sort of
deciding what to do with leftover space
and so that meant we could then use them
in grid layout so we get this kind of
common layout system building up which
works in the same way no matter which
layout method you're using but in terms
of new CSS I wanted to talk about
something else that is now part of the
box alignment spec so we have these gap
features now CSS grid layout implemented
these gap features gap row gap and
column gap we also have multi color we
also have a column gap feature which is
really the sort of the first thing that
allowed us to do this kind of spacing
out of columns now they started in the
grid layout spec and these gap features
but they've now been put into box
alignment because actually gaps between
things fit quite nicely with other space
distribution type properties so
initially in grid layout we had grid
column gap grid row gap and grid gap as
a shorthand which basically gives you
these gutters or alleys or whatever
between the tracks and not on the
outside
they were then moved into box alignment
and so renamed to column gap row gap and
gap I think most browsers have now
implemented the renamed properties but
we're kind of keeping the old grid pre
fixed ones hanging around probably
forevermore because things people had
already built sites by that point so be
kept as aliases but now they've been
renamed we've got column gap row gap and
gap as a shorthand they then make sense
if you're in Flex layout which means
that you would be able to do gaps
between Flex items rather than having to
put a margin on either side and then
doing a negative margin to pull the
things out which once you've you
gridlayout seems utterly baffling and
flexbox that were happy to do this weird
thing with margins to get gaps so we're
going to have gaps in flex layout it's
in the spec and it works in Firefox at
the moment they've shipped their
implementation I think they're the only
ones who have currently shipped the
implementation this is the charts from
mdn showing how we've got support in
Flex layout isn't great yet because it's
pretty new and no-one's really
implemented it but then we have support
in grid layout which is it's good other
than obviously Internet Explorer which
doesn't have the gaps and they've got
their older implementation of grid which
didn't have any kind of gutter
properties but hope you will not have to
wait too long for support in other
browsers Firefox that there's fairly
quickly which was great so this is
another concept which is part of grid
layout but it's becoming increasingly
important across that layout stuff on
the web it's sort of idea of intrinsic
sizing have been able to size things
based on the content of that item as
opposed to kind of explicitly setting
and extrinsic with saying you know I
want you to be this big you can say well
how big is my content can you be that
big can you be big enough for the
content so these intrinsic sizing
keywords have been implemented in grid
layout for track sizing so you can kind
of play around with them there and they
work anywhere that grid layout is
implemented so if I have three tracks at
min content size so I'm basically I'm
using repeat three min content I've got
three tracks min content so our grid
ends up looking like this so if I say
min content what happens is the track
will get as small as it possibly can if
all of your tracks are just full of
words the track will essentially become
as wide as the longest word all the soft
wrapping opportunities will be taken to
collapse the sort of content of the
tracks down to that width so that's then
no overflows can happen it's not gonna
get smaller than the content
small as it can obviously you've got
something in there which has a set width
that's going to cause the width so if
you put an image in there and so this
image is 500 pixels well that's how big
the track is going to be if you've got
text in there it'll just collapse down
so that's min content and we have the
opposite we have max content so if you
say you want something at max content
it's going to do the opposite it's going
to get as big as it possibly can and it
won't do any wrapping and obviously if
things don't wrap at all probably's
going to happen it's gonna break out of
the box so the border there is the size
of the grids and we've now got tracks
that are actually too big to fit into
the grid which is why by default we
don't max content sized things on the
web but if you want to actually know how
big something is max content will give
you that in grid layout we've got a
keyword fit content that allows you to
pass in a value and this is incredibly
useful because it gives you that kind of
max content capability until you get to
a certain size and then you start
wrapping so whatever you've passed in
and then in this case I've passed in 10m
so it can be at max content until it
gets to 10m and then starts doing the
wrapping behavior so you get something
like this so the first track has got 210
m and started wrapping the second track
never gets to 10 M so it just goes to
max content and the third track does the
wrapping at 10 M so you can use those in
grid if you can use grid layout you can
use those size and keywords they'll
implement it everywhere where they're
quite useful I use them for things I
have very flexible components so say
I've got a component that has maybe a
little icon in sometimes but maybe a
bigger image that I'd like to sort of
resize down so I've set its max width to
100% you know I can say fit content and
the biggest size I ever want that to get
and then what happens is if it's a small
image it shrinks down and but if it's a
bigger image it will stop at that fit
content size I've passed in so they're
kind of nice ways to play around making
more flexible components rather than
having to make lots of components and
put a clasp on them to say oh this is
the one where my image is this
this is another one where my image is so
big but what we are going to be able to
do is then use them everywhere else on
the web Chrome has implemented min and
Max content which you can use instead of
a length when you are say setting a
width or anything else so you can say
just width min content or with Max
content so allowing you to actually size
any element doesn't have to be in a grid
based on those sizing keywords so you'll
end up with something like that you
could have a something size to the min
content or max content we're going to be
seeing this kind of thing a lot more and
our new layout methods are much better
at dealing with kind of distributing
space and so on and so we can start
looking at the content rather than just
sort of setting everything to be a
certain size and then squishing content
into it so away from layouts to say I
have a lot more layouts of tomorrow if
that's thing particularly interested in
I wanted to look at some of the other
things that have been implemented
recently and something we are doing
quite a lot is looking at what people
are doing with JavaScript and say well
can we do this in CSS in a more
performant way because typically if
you're doing things you know directly in
CSS it's going to perform better than
something which is implemented on top in
in JavaScript so one of those things is
scroll snapping this is this idea what
when you're sort of scrolling through
something I'm seeing if you you know
working with an app and when you drag
and it kind of snaps to the sort of best
points you don't kind of have to keep on
sliding it and lining it up you can
actually say well I would like this to
snap to a certain point and that's what
scrolled snapping lets us do I know this
has been recently implemented in Chrome
there is an older version of the spec
implemented in some other browsers
Firefox for example still implements a
kind of early version like a kind of
prototype version of the spec and chrome
has the the newer version implemented so
this is kind of where it looks like so
here I'm making the body the squirrel
con
and so I'm saying I want schools snap
type X I want to be on the x-axis and
make it mandatory so it kind of has to
snap there and then on the the child
item I'm setting my scroll snap a line
to start so this hopefully will let me
sort of snap something on the x-axis as
I'm scrolling and we'll go to the start
of my images so you've got something
like this and hopefully little video
will play and so because we sort of drag
it you see it kind of bounces back if I
don't get all the way across then if I
get across it kind of bounces onto the
next one
not an ideal thing to show on on a video
but you can play around with with the
demo online you can also do the little
box doesn't have to be the whole page
that you scroll snapping you might be
have some element which has a scrollbar
and you can use scroll snapping in that
so here I've got a list and let's say
I'm going to do the y-axis and I'm just
going to snap to the top of my list
items so we've got little box here as we
sort of drag it it snaps to the next the
next item or bounces back up if I don't
drag very far so it's quite a nice
little spec for doing that kind of thing
and if you're building things that are
sort of certainly more app-like
experiences on the web and these things
in a nice little enhancements you only
need to be a little bit careful you
don't end up making something always
bounce away so people can't scroll to
the bottom of the box and so on
and there's different types of Scrolls
nothing in the spec that you can play
around with again you know all this
stuff doesn't need careful testing I
find that as we're getting so much new
stuff it just all raises new kind of
accessibility problems and new things
that we actually do have to remember to
test
now in a 5.5 you could color your scroll
bars and if you're as old as me you can
remember what the web looked like we're
picking it back as a standard I'm not
quite sure why but we are so we're in
2018 we're standardizing colored scroll
bars with the CSS scroll bars spec and
Firefox have been implementing it so you
have to scroll bar color and that
basically lets you color the thumbs the
bit that's or slides up and down and
also the track and in the next slide you
can see why I don't do any design but
you know so you can color your scroll
bars that's in Firefox nightly I think
you still need to enable the flags to
see it but yes we're getting these
colored scroll bars essentially this is
a standardization of something that
browsers were already doing and that's
something you do see so like well people
do this thing let's do it in a standard
way rather than have everyone implement
their own weird way of doing it we've
also got scroll bar width which is quite
useful if you've got small components
you can ask the browser the user agent
to use its thin scrollbar and you see
what we're not doing here is saying
something absolute we're basically
saying you know if this user agent has a
thin version of their scrollbar I think
I would like to use it there's a bit
more of a suggestion than a sort of
absolute I want it to be so big so
obviously the default scrollbar as a
thin scrollbar you can also use
scrollbar with none which will not show
a scrollbar at all but will make the
items still scrollable you have seen to
be careful with that because people need
to know that they can still scroll but
if you are implementing some kinds of
other scrolling or your design is just
very much for a tablet and it's gonna be
obvious that you're gonna be able to
scroll it then you could always turn off
the scroll bars but obviously again
that's thing you'd be quite careful off
because you could end up with things
people don't realize they can scroll
down so here's a thin scrollbar in
nightly and that will is say be varied
that much down to the user-agent exactly
what that looks like but it
you choose the thin one if that suits
what you're doing now I wanted to talk a
little bit about shapes as CSS shapes
isn't a particularly a new thing it's
been around for quite a long time and
this is a spec that came from Adobe
you know not all specs come from browser
vendors CSS shapes came from Adobe and
it allows you to curve text around
things that aren't square boxes which is
unusual on the web and the reason I'm
doing so is it's recently just being
shipped in Firefox so we've actually got
very good browsers pop CSS shapes
there's only edge now that doesn't have
support what a way to show though I was
saying that I think a lot of people
don't realize you can do with shapes and
that's you can use a gradient as the
shape and the Alpha Channel support and
shapes to sort of do some interesting
things so what I've got here is a linear
gradient and then I'm using shape image
threshold to set the threshold that I
want that shape to be used on so I've
basically got the same linear gradient
set as a background and used as the
value of shape outside just like our
could use the image which you can see
gives me this the text is now going
along the line of that gradient but the
interesting thing about using gradients
like that is that we obviously don't
necessarily want to do something that
looks like it came from the 1990s but
you can use your gradient to create a
shape but not actually show the gradient
at all so here I'm just using that
gradient kind of as a mask and as the
value of shape outside and that gives me
my angle text so that's kind of useful
you can do the same thing with an image
you can create an image with a
transparent area to use as the value of
shape outside never show the image on
the page but use the the shape of the
image the transparent part as a mask to
create your CSS shapes that's a much
easier way to create shapes than the
other way which is to use the sort of
basic shape types and create a polygon
and sort of poke it all around to try
and get the shape you want so much easy
just to use an image so that's CSS
shapes if you've not played around with
a shape spec it's now got really good
browser support really nice to use an
enhancement because obviously if
for your design calls for angled text
and the browser does not support shapes
that user doesn't get angled text but
they can still read the content it's all
fine
so shapes is something that's a really
nice way to sort of enhance your layouts
really the only thing you have to watch
out for with that is if you were angling
the text to avoid an untidy background
image for example and you might want to
do something to give older browsers a
view that pushed the content away from
the image or didn't show the image or
something but yeah shapes is a nice one
to use as an enhancement and while
talking about gradients conic gradients
sassoon that Lia Varun has spoke about
for a long time she's been very keen to
see conic gradients get into CSS and
they are now specified as part of images
level 4 and so we can we've got an
implementation in chrome so you can
start to play around with those now the
conic gradient is really nice we can we
can create a that looks like a cone
which is a sort of default use of a
conic gradient and I'm creating here and
a green and orange cone and you get so
it looks like that but you can also do
things like create a pie chart out of
conic gradients by adding hard stops
further colors so rather than sort of
having it gradient in just sort of
stopping chunks of the color as you go
around the circle um you can end up with
a pie chart using just one line of CSS
that's that gives you that you can also
create pac-man which I created pac-man
by mistake while trying to create a pie
chart and I thought that's pac-man so
there we go if you like as I say it's
just in Chrome at the moment leo has
been talking about this for a long time
has a CSS conic gradient polyfill if you
sort of really need them
of course the other thing you could do
is you could create if you were say
using conic gradients for charts you
could create your pie chart with a conic
gradient and you could load an image for
non supporting browsers
have you or presentation a different way
anyway that's just a nice little
addition to the lower for Images spec
another way of doing gradients now while
we're here I want to talk a little bit
about some of the things that Firefox
have been doing because if you're using
some of these new CSS features Firefox
dev tools have a whole bunch of really
great tools for designing for the web
and I think this is really interesting
they're sort of dev tools stuff that's
going on at chrome have already gone
down the line of all their performance
tools so they've got some fantastic
performance tools in chrome firefox are
taking a bit of a different approach and
they've really put a lot of resources
into creating tools for designing with
CSS which if you are working with you
know any of the things they've created a
tool for it's really useful especially
things like grid you can't see the grid
areas easily you can't add your own
borders to them unless you've got an
element in there so now to use dev tools
to inspect things is really useful if
you're using Firefox as a development
browser get yourself a copy of Firefox
nightly because all of the new work and
and they're constantly working on these
tools all of the new stuff ends up in
nightly so if you're using Firefox
development browser download the nightly
Edition I mean I pretty much used
Firefox nightly all the time and it's
you know it's pretty stable
but it will get all the new stuff new
features of CSS but also the new dev
tools so for instance we've got the grid
layout tools which they really have and
Chrome's got a very very basic grid
layout tool but it kind of just
highlights the cells the Firefox tool
lets you really see the grid lets you
see where your items are aligned within
the grid and you can kind of play around
you can obviously change things in the
CSS it's really useful the grid
inspector there so the things they've
got said I've got the grid tool they've
got a flexbox tool which may not be in
the shipping version of the browser it
might just be a nightly at the moment
they've got to shoot their CSS shapes
inspector which shipped with their
shapes implementation recently as you
can inspect basic shapes and also if you
are using that the polygon you can
adjust the polygon actually in the dev
tools and then copy that out in CS CSS
so it's quite a good way to mess around
with your shapes and they've also got
tools for variable fonts which shipping
in all the browsers at the moment to
adjust the different axes of the fonts
and play around with them and see how
that works so I really would recommend
you have a look if you haven't already
out the Firefox dev tools and get
nightly so you can play with all the
latest stuff I think they they were also
very keen to hear feedback from people
who are working with the tools as to
what would be useful
I found them fairly useful when teaching
groups of designers new CSS to be able
to say right you know here's this open
up in Firefox let's actually have a look
and a play around so can be useful for
sharing the stuff for the members of
your team you know more accessible way
than them just looking at the CSS to
play around actually with those dev
tools so what's coming up next you know
what have we been discussing in the
working group what are we hoping to see
in browsers really soon so there's a
whole load of stuff there's always tons
of different things being discussed we
follow along gets hope you'll find that
we're talking about all sorts of stuff
I've picked out a couple of things that
interest me one of those is this issue
of aspect ratio on the web we've not
really got a good way of dealing with
aspect ratios so if you've got something
which has an aspect ratio so an image
video what-have-you
we've been doing sort of things like
using this padding hack to try and show
aspect ratio which works most the time
but it would be nice just to have an
aspect ratio unit it would nice just be
able to say you know I want this other
dimension of this to retain the aspect
ratio of the thing that I'm working with
we've got a very rough spec we were
talking about it at the recent meeting
for doing these aspect ratio units
that link will take you to the draft
spec which also links to the issues on
github where we're discussing it lots
and lots of people from the community
are also discussing aspect ratio units
if you have thoughts on that matter or
you think you might have thoughts on
that matter we'd be very interested it's
good to see as many use cases as
possible it turns out that developing
new CSS is pretty much like developing
the feature of any product the more use
cases you can see of how people might
need to use that feature the better you
can make the feature the thing with the
web is once we've shipped something into
browsers we probably can't change it so
the more stuff we can get up front or
more information and get from the
community as to how things have been
used and the better we can make what
ends up in browsers quite a lot of those
discussions come down to what should we
call this thing I'm sure you're aware
that many things in CSS are called very
strange things and that's because of
history and the fact we can't really
change stuff easily so that's something
that's that's kind of coming up isn't in
any browsers yet it's just an over state
but hopefully we'll see relatively soon
now I have a few little sort of pet
things in CSS that I like to go on about
and I I kind of think the more I talk
about them the more I might be able to
make them kind of happen and exclusions
is one of them I'd really like to see
some progress of this now exclusions is
implemented in IE 10 and up but it's
only Microsoft browsers that have an
implementation of this it didn't come
from Microsoft this came from Adobe and
it was part of the CSS shape spec so
shapes was shapes and exclusions and
then the suspect was split and the shape
spec carried on and exclusions kind of
sat there which i think is sad and I'll
sort of show you why that I think that's
a shame so exclusions at one point was
called positioned floats which i think
is quite descriptive of it because it
allows you to sort of flow text around
all sides of an element so you know if
you float something it can either go
left or right and the content then wraps
around
with the exclusions you could sort of
pop something right in the middle of
your document and have the text wrapping
round both sides so it specifies this
wrap flow property as we save that flow
both you want the content to flow around
both sides the SE is only implemented in
Microsoft browsers with the MS prefix so
the demos I've got here and the things
I've got online and only work in edge or
I guess in old II's
although most amusing read so you need
to use edge for them but with the prefix
and so you get something like this here
what I'm doing is I'm positioning the
element with grid layout sort of on top
of the text and then I use that map flow
property which says actually just flow
the text around this thing which is here
now this is useful in a number of use
cases it's kind of like a neat thing to
be able to do to stick by everything in
the middle in so a lot of editorial
design that's exactly what you want you
want to go to position items and then
you want to build a flow text in and you
want the text just to respect the
position of the item you don't want to
have to say oh well this item has to be
at the start of this paragraph so I can
use float so even if things are left or
right aligned often you don't actually
know where they're going to come but you
want them to be in a certain point in
the document and I should have wrote up
this use case because I had someone send
me a problem they were having with grid
and it was basically this they were
saying well I can't float an item
anymore because if something's floated
and then it becomes a grid item it stops
being floated it becomes a grid item
which is useful if you're trying to
override a floated layout with grid
layout but not if you actually do want
to floated item and I think it's that
sort of thing that exclusions would
solve and so I sort of wrote it up and
did some demos that do work in edge
and then we've got Houdini because it
might be that the layout method that you
want is never going to be implemented by
the CSS working group because it isn't
kind of general enough you've got
something very specific that you want to
be able to do in your very specific
circumstance but it doesn't matter how
much you ask it's not general enough
we're not going to be able to kind of
implement that and that's what Houdini
really comes for this is a project that
aims to expose low-level api's making it
possible for you to write your own
extensions to CSS using javascript and
there's a few reasons to do that one
would be to create really good polyfills
for features that aren't influenced in
all browsers another reason would be to
experiment with things and then be able
to propose them back - this is us
working group and say hey look it would
be great if we had this I have built
something that kind of works using
Houdini but it'll be much better if it
was kind of part of CSS and easier for
other people I mean the other thing is
to do those kind of custom things that
are never going to become part of part
of CSS and because it's basically
letting you get into those underlying
api's it's been much more performance
than the current way we do this sort of
stuff with JavaScript now Houdini is at
a very early stage but you can use it a
lot of this stuff you can use in Chrome
Canary if you want to have a play around
you to enable the experimental web
platform features flags so here's an
example of a polyfill being used so this
is that chronic gradient polyfill used
with Houdini just an example it's online
you can have a look at so that that
would be an example of poly filling
something with Houdini and these are
from Vincent D'Onofrio his site so
perhaps you want a gradient that doesn't
exist at all this corners gradient you
want this very specific gradient well
you could create that using Houdini and
a key use would be to create layouts in
a more performant way so if you're
familiar with the masonry layout method
where you can sort of it's not quite
grid it's not quite flexbox you've
basically got boxes that kind of push up
into sort to make room for the
from boxes you can do that with
JavaScript it doesn't perform very well
at scale this is a really good use case
or something like Houdini it may be at
some point that we do specify something
like this that the CSS working group I
know there's a lot of people would like
to have an inbuilt CSS masonary but it's
the sort of thing that Houdini would
also let you do to to create your own
sort of masonry or whatever layout type
that you want I don't have time to go
dive into this today but this site Sam
Richards created this site Houdini blitz
taught me which is a kind of interactive
introduction to the different API so you
can play around with some of the things
that work if you use Chrome with with
the flags enabled and sermons created
this chart is Houdini ready yet which
her detail is the different API so got
the layout API paint the parser and
properties and values well he's
different API is that are going to be
used for Houdini and you can see the
status of them and sort of where they're
getting to so that's fine that is that
is happening it's doing that every CSS
working group meeting there's some time
put aside discuss Houdini and to move it
forward
it's obviously complex because every
browser is different and so actually
exposes api s-- is different for every
browser but it's something we're getting
to and I think it's quite exciting if
you ask someone who can write javascript
polyfills at the moment or is able to
kind of you know do layout stuff looking
into Houdini I think is going to be very
exciting over the next couple of years
and so having shown you a bunch of cool
stuff and I know from experience there
will be some of you wondering why anyone
is expending brain energy looking at
things that aren't in browsers yet and
when you program your to use for at
least a decade but things are improving
in that way things are moving an awful
lot more quickly into browsers we're
seeing things implemented at a much
faster rate and we've also got things
built into CSS to help us do this now
CSS itself is great at progressive
enhancement if a browser comes across
any bit of CSS that doesn't understand
it just goes I don't know what they says
and ignores it completely it doesn't do
anything we
it just ignores it which means that you
can use new stuff in your browser and as
long as it just sort of fails silently
that's fine
so something like CSS shapes you could
just use it and if you don't get the
shape that's probably okay you can use
thing as an enhancement the problem
comes where you've got you've done some
old stuff and then you want to do some
new stuff but something in the new stuff
would kind of leak through to the old
layout you know for instance if you have
you know you're building a float layout
you're gonna enhance it with grid the
float would be ignored by grid but the
width you've applied to the items to
make your floated layout work will be
interpreted by the grid layout and will
make things smaller than you want them
so you kind of want to be able to fork
your code so we've got feature queries
in CSS which let you detect support and
do things when you know you've got
support
they look bit like a media query except
we're using app supports rather than app
media and what you do is you test a
property and value so here I'm saying at
supports and then I've used background
connect gradient so I'm looking to see
if the browser has the chronic gradient
support if it does have chronic gradient
support that I'm going to use it but if
it doesn't what I've done first is I've
used a linear gradient so that means if
you don't have support you'll get the
linear gradient if you do have support
you should get the conic gradient see
you get something like this I'm so you
know in Firefox whatever you would get
the linear gradient so feature queries
are incredibly useful to help us kind of
progressively enhance our CSS in a sort
of a sensible way in a way that allows
us to to not worry too much about using
the new things we're not going to cause
your bad things happening in the old
browser say particularly useful when
using older late layout methods like
floats and then overriding them
typically I have a stack of selectors
which were I'm just knocking off the
width and the margins that I've used to
make my older layout work once I'm in
grid and the other reason to start using
this new stuff as well as the fat it's
cool and you can enhance your
and do all sorts of interesting things
that have become little enhancements the
other reason to start using the new
stuff is that you get to kind of
influence the process to some extent
because you can talk to us as I
mentioned everything's happening in the
open we really really appreciate the CSS
working group getting feedback from
people who are using CSS so by using
some of this stuff particularly when
it's at a really early stage that's the
chance to change it if something is
behind a flag in a browser and you can
look at it and you can say hey hang on
that doesn't work very well I've got got
a better idea I can see a problem at
that point we can probably change it
once it shipped in two browsers we
probably can't change it because it's
out there people are using it for their
projects and so it is worth kind of
finding out what's hidden behind flags
and playing around with it because then
you can help influence that process very
very few people do the few people who
actually get engaged the process have
you know quite an awful lot of influence
in terms of the way things go because so
people do get involved with early stage
specs so that's one way to influence the
future of CSS is to find out what's
coming and talk to us about it that'd be
great the other thing is start telling
browsers what you want and you can do
that in a whole bunch of ways you can
raise issues with browsers there's you
know the book trackers online you can go
and say hey I want you to implement this
or you've implemented this and it's
broken or you don't play this and it's
now different in the spec to what you
did you can add new use cases to issues
that's often very helpful and it shows
as well as interest writing and talking
about this stuff you know I keep talking
about exclusions because I would like to
see progress and you know actually
telling more people about it hopefully
will help with that but also use the
features there all of the browsers are
inspecting what people are using no
browser wants to be the only browser
there's not implemented something that
everyone else is using so it makes their
browser look broken so if you're using
the stuff that is going to be noted so
even if you can only use it on a
personal site that helps to kind of
build the amount of sites that are using
that particular feature makes it more
likely
we'll end up in the browser that isn't
currently supporting it so thank you
very much for listening to this rundown
as I say everything is online and I'm
happy to take a few questions if I've
got time or you can sort of track me
down later thank you very much
[Applause]